[Música]
bienvenidos a en 5 minutos con hoy vamos
a hablar del break city con nicolás
murillo docentes de relaciones
internacionales de la universidad
externado de colombia magister en
cooperación internacional unión europea
y américa latina muchas gracias por
estar en france 24 profesor el tiempo se
acaba para el break sheet literalmente
el jueves los líderes de la unión
europea sostienen su última reunión del
año y este día se menciona ya como fecha
límite para que estudien un eventual
acuerdo si es una fecha límite puede
haber más oportunidades de llegar a un
acuerdo antes del 31 de diciembre
muy buenos días muchas gracias por su
invitación bueno es difícil es difícil
leer el futuro no tengo una bola de
cristal pero lo que sí es seguro es que
el acuerdo del break se es un acuerdo
político y como todo acuerdo político si
bien tiene fechas límites estas fechas
límites están escritas solamente en el
papel y la realidad es que si lo
quisieran en la presidenta de la
comisión europea en boris johnson o
michel barnier podría sentarse sin
dormir durante 21 días a punta de café y
tratar de buscar una solución entonces
de que pueden haber otras fechas pueden
haberla la pregunta es si políticamente
es sostenible para ambas partes a la vez
que se anuncia que boris johnson debe ir
a bruselas para reunirse con la
presidenta de la comisión europea ursula
von der leyen en la cámara de los
comunes se aprobó la ley de mercado
interno que tiene algunas cláusulas
violatorias del trato de salida en
especial respecto a irlanda del norte y
que generan reticencias en europa es
esto una manera del primer ministro
británico de poner presión a la
contraparte para que se dé en otros
puntos
francamente no creo que sea una presión
para que se da en otros puntos
es una presión ya que demuestra que está
dispuesto a digamos a infringir los
acuerdos que ya se firmaron y esto
también es una presión para que la unión
europea acepte este punto en particular
y renunciar de pronto a la cuestión
irlandesa en el sentido en que pues
muestra su determinación y al mostrar su
determinación está efectivamente dando
una muy mala señal para los negociadores
de pronto intentando forzar les la mano
pero pues los negociadores europeos por
primera vez en la historia de la unión
europea en lo que trata de inglaterra
gran bretaña han mostrado una voluntad
de hierro también y esto es lo que nos
hace pensar que estamos cada vez más
cerca realmente el móvil a menos que sea
un gran juego de blog tipo póker cuáles
son a su juicio o profesor los temas más
espinosos más difíciles que están
haciendo tan difícil llegar a un acuerdo
y qué escenarios ve en alguno de ellos
bueno hay varios pero creo que en primer
lugar es el tema de irlanda el tema de
irlanda del norte del pacto entre
comillas que sigue pues digamos en el
centro de las negociaciones en el
sentido en que los acuerdos del viernes
santo son muy importantes para la unión
europea y son muy importantes para
irlanda como miembros de la unión
europea y en este sentido digamos que la
unión está negociando
a nombre de los dedos de los irlandeses
y en ese sentido este tema es muy
espinoso porque los británicos muchos lo
ven y algunos apoyos de boris johnson en
el parlamento que garantizan su uso su
bondad su mandato su mandato digámoslo
así lo ven como una pérdida de soberanía
y como una traición es franca del primer
ministro entonces en ese orden de ideas
este tema ya de por sí es muy complicado
después tenemos el tema evidentemente de
los subsidios el tema de los pescadores
ante la del acceso de los europeos a las
aguas británicas para pescar y
finalmente tenemos el tema de las reglas
del juego fiscal tributario y comercial
que son finalmente una de las bases del
break británico es una autonomía total
para firmar acuerdos con el mundo entero
y seguir las reglas que ellos quisieran
el británico se comprometió a no
volverse una competencia desleal pero al
mismo tiempo no quiere seguir o no
quiere armonizar sus normas sus
normativas fiscales y comerciales con
las de la unión entonces también esto es
un problema para el once europea y bueno
eso es vital
este profesor me de no me quiero
despedir porque ya nos quedan 40
segunditos ya nos dijo que no tiene una
bola de cristal pero si tiene
perspectiva de experto o profesor es
posible un acuerdo antes del 31 de
diciembre nos quedan veinte segundos
perdón posible siempre lo han mostrado
la vez pasada hasta el último hasta el
último segundo es posible
si hay voluntad de las partes pero
francamente en este instante lo veo
complicado muy bien nicolás murillo
muchas gracias él es docente de
relaciones internacionales de la
universidad externado de colombia y
muchas gracias a ustedes siga con
nosotros en francés 24
[Música]